oui je suis candidat à la présidence de
la république à lui aujourd'hui de
trouver les mots les comportements les
attitudes pour réunir pour fédérer pour
pour rassembler je suis pas fâché du
tout je les ponceaux pas coupé mais il
appelle pas son porte parole pour
annoncer sa candidature à la
présidentielle
c'est au delà des mots c'est une
conviction totale
je veux tout donner tout donner pour la
france qui m'a tant donné
le président de la république française
sortant qui devait être candidat à sa
propre succession se retrouvent dans
l'incapacité de se présenter parce que
et macron evans ont tout organisé pour
le faire renoncer
et lorsqu'on pense que c'est françois
hollande qui a fait leur carrière
et bien voilà c'est le combat des
traîtres à gauche aujourd'hui pour les
raisons que je vous ai dit je vous
prendrait du temps et je ferai mon choix
avec le recul nécessaire par ailleurs
l'huile et c'est l'essai on est en train
d'essayer d'empêcher de parler et je
vois pas pourquoi on m'appelle serait de
parler
et pourquoi il y aurait une telle
autorité intel mise en scène pour ça les
choses sont vous invitent jeudi à
françois hollande je veux dire mon
émotion mon affection
sa décision est celle d'un homme d'état
qui place l'intérêt général au-dessus de
tout dommage qu'il a rendu à françois
hollande a dû faire sourire beaucoup de
hollandais
quand on sait qu'il a achevée
politiquement le premier le président la
république il ya quelques jours donc je
crois que manuel valls il très bon sur
les estrades mais il nous a montré le
contraire quand il était premier
ministre
le problème n'est pas d'être le candidat
de la gauche ou même de gagner une
primaire
le problème est de savoir comment on est
unis non pas autour d'un homme
providentiel d'une femme providentiel
mais autour de nos valeurs
on sent qu'il a du mal à garder ses
nerfs et on le voit souvent très énervé
très agressif
ce qui n'est pas rassurant pour
quelqu'un qui veut maîtriser le bouton
nucléaire où l'ensemble des
responsabilités qui incombent un chef de
l'état marque ait pu avoir
des mots durs susciter des débats des
incompréhensions
c'est ça la gauche c'est le débat c'est
la controverse mais j'ai toujours assumé
les décisions collectives parce que
c'est ça aussi l'esprit de la gauche
aurez vous connaissez un meilleur
candidat
tuchan j'en connaissais ah oui et je
serai présente dans ce clair un candidat
qui représente le coeur des valeurs du
parti socialiste est pas évident on va
voir c'est lui qui avait voulu je crois
des pâtes débaptiser le parti socialiste
filât il a un certain nombre d'éléments
à son actif biographique qui montre qu'
il n'était pas toujours finalement dans
la tradition politique que je revenant
mais après tout je ne donne aucune leçon
à personne ce que doit être la cause
quant à emmanuel macron en voyage à new
york il n'a pas souhaité commenter cette
candidature concurrente depuis
l'étranger
[Musique]